teller Honaker worked for the bush
reagan campaign in 1980 and then quit
and in in a volatile protest of their
activities and has made a crusade out of
exposing the October Surprise Minaj will
get into this and so this is one of the
stories that was covered over by the
mainstream media was her initial story
well her initial story was that the
Reagan Bush campaign William Casey the
Reagan Bush campaign had made a deal
with the Iranians to keep the Embassy
hostage through the elections and then
another 76 days so that Carter wouldn't
even get credit for their release you
know so that Reagan would get the full
credit for their release and they were
in fact released two hours after he was
sworn in which was enough time for the
word to get back to Iran that he was in
fact president and then he you know they
were the the hostages were released they
were actually held at the airport
waiting for this confirmation and then
to go back to our other thing we were
working on here is why didn't Dukakis
take Bush's head off that stuff which he
could have got knows you can see the
television commercials are shows in our
interview five-minute segments showing
the Noriega linka the black eagle the
whole stuff we had all of this and we
were definitely trying to feed it to
them and what what what we got back from
them was this is from the Dukakis caucus
and we got inside we got we got we got
the movie cover up delivered to them we
got the movie the PBS Frontline show
guns drugs and the CI delivered to them
we got in to see them some of the people
in this broad disorganized group of
scholars researching this thing and we
we we got from them a resistance they
they they essentially and feedback as
one of the the senior dukakis people
told Jim Driscoll who's in our community
with the Americas peace test in Nevada
that John sparkles facts are all screwed
up and and I you know I immediately what
facts what is it because I consider
myself if not an academic nevertheless a
scholar these things and so what facts
because I want to check them out because
if I am scrap I don't you know I don't
and they wouldn't give us any details
but they just rejected the stuff out of
hand now if you permit me just very
quickly to create a scenario or give you
my analysis what happened and we note
the scandal broke or was broken by the
establishment in November of 86
iran-contra scandal and it led to a
dismantling of the Reagan White House
and then later they gave him his
credibility back with the INF agreement
now in the winter of 1987 the the George
Bush was written up by every major
columnist as being out of business he
was finished politically they were
saying this openly
George Will was writing columns that the
Republican Party was out the Democrats
were clearly going to win the next time
around and they were all writing that
George Bush could not survive the
iran-contra scandal and this is because
they including the conservative
columnist and the establishment press
had this material back then right and
they knew about George Bush's
involvement in all of this stuff and the
scandal was breaking and they did not
believe that he could survive right by
the spring he had survived to the point
battling as I as I put it to stay out of
jail he had hung in there he didn't
resign or retire and they began to
wonder what the u.s. of people's
tolerance was of this scandal how much
it would stick then they engineered the
iran-contra hearings in the summer which
were carefully orchestrated by Danny
Inouye the Democrat in cooperation with
the other Democrats Cohen and Mitchell
for example wrote the book
men of zeal which they profess to be an
expose abide the scenes but they do not
in fact expose it's a continuation of
the cover-up
they do not for example discuss their
resistance at having of allowing the
black eagle stuff to be investigated and
their their own resistance of having the
George Bush drug linkage investigated so
the committee drew a line and said we
won't investigate beyond this line so
they gave the nation the appearance of
an airing and they did not in fact probe
into the things that would have led them
into the impeachment of George Bush and
this had a catharsis effect on the
nation and then we get into the the fall
and in the winter of 88 and in the
spring and there's still a debate going
on in public remember Dan Rather who
tried to nail Bush and tried to break
this stuff in a CBS interview and what
happened was the establishment came down
on him and said no we you know we're not
going to go after George Bush until
eventually in the summer of 88 when we
were once again trying to break this
Bush eventually was able to laugh at the
cameras at the Republican convention
because we had journalists I mean we had
found journalists who would ask the
questions who went up on national
television and said what about the
iran-contra thing and he just laughed at
him and said I'm not even going to
answer those questions anymore the
nation doesn't care about the
iran-contra scandal that is history I've
answered those questions forget it don't
ask me anymore now in the meantime this
establishment this party that we have
the single party state this fraternity
that runs this country that has two
chapters a Republican and a Democrat one
a little bit more liberal and the other
one one more conservative representing
them the big business interests more
directly that's the Republicans in terms
of their interest that's the 18 but they
always have the b-team that they can run
out a Jimmy Carter when Richard Nixon
makes the nation too angry or the nation
gets too riled at the Vietnam War or
something like that this is where they
produced Michael Dukakis he's a team
player to the establishment in order to
be accepted as
presidential candidate he did homage to
the to the arms race he said eventually
that he would give humanitarian aid to
the Contras he would consider it he said
definitely he would give military aid to
El Salvador which means he bought into
all the principles of the covert secret
government of the covert operations of
the covert manipulation of the world he
was singing another song when he was
trying to get the Democratic nomination
that's right before his background was
progressive but he he bought it they
screened him into the system they
groomed him into the system he was
advised that he could run but if he
would so what he was there is he if the
nation had clung had its outrage had
been sufficient over the iran-contra
scandal they had Dukakis standing by the
b-team to their interests and he would
give them some grief by spending some
money on housing and on medical
insurance for people and things like
that
which is not their choice of the way to
invest the money they want to invest it
in missiles and things where they make
greater profits but he would support the
arms race and he would support the CIA
and the covert establishment the
National Security States activities but
then they realized they did not have to
go with the b-team the people didn't
care they didn't have to give the nation
a beat team so they went ahead and went
with the 18 which was George Bush ie
they concluded eventually that they
could Teflon eyes Bush despite all of
this incredible activity and selling to
the nation and they did why though did
Dukakis as the b-team not go after Bush
more aggressively because he's a member
of the team he's a member of the
fraternity why did Danny no way they had
they had Ronald Reagan and George Bush
by the short hairs
they could have impeached them and they
didn't because they couldn't impeach a
popular president like Reagan and Bush
without losing control the public trust
see this gets back into the Howards End
thesis that the American Revolution
occurred when the rich white people rich
white males over here wanted to take
power away from the same element
England and they engineered a deal with
the people whereby they would give more
freedom to the people than they had
under the monarchy or the colony but
nevertheless the rich white males would
retain control and and this this dynamic
relationship we don't have a democracy
we do not even to this day a vote for
the president we vote for electors who
select the president in addition to
which this two-party system we've
evolved gives them further control
because even the selection of the
candidates it's done by about 50% vote a
popular vote through the primaries and
about 50% through the frozen delegates
of the hard delegates of the
super-delegates who are party hacks who
control you know the party machinery
controlling ultimately who gets
nominated this is why Pat Schroeder gave
it a run and dropped out is because her
traveling and consulting with the
super-delegates the frozen delegates the
power structure of the party she was
told she would not be permitted to win
whatever happened you know in the
popular side of things and then once
that was decided you know the money was
not available to her now this system as
it and as it has continued for 200 years
is a tenuous relationship in which the
people who own the country the people on
the foot you know who the Federal
Reserve Board the people who manage the
money and and the moneyed interests the
strength of the capitalist system these
people know that they're writing a
potentially rebellious horse and the
American people whose interests are not
being fully served myth has to be
maintained to make this thing run and
it's a constant balance of what do they
have to give the people to keep them
onboard the system and at what point are
they going to lose the system you read
the history through Zen's eyes of the
United States or the grameen gum book on
the history of violence in the United
States and you see that every time the
people have become angry enough the
system as you
into them the labor struggles at the
turn of the century for example the
Vietnam War in civil rights days when
blacks rose up in the country with a
massive boycott and it began to really
hurt the economic interests
the small businesses and the ghettos and
white business like this at Detroit and
Watts and 14th Street in Washington and
you know when the when the nation when
the system was breaking apart the
establishment yielded every time and the
system self-destructed the cynicism of
the Reagan years in which one of the
more dramatic transfers of wealth from
the poor to the rich occurred you know
was orchestrated by Ronald Reagan
through the arms race the two trillion
dollars in arms the mechanisms that he
set up for him that rigging of the taxes
where he could say taxes had been cut
when they had been redistributed to hurt
the middle class and poor more this
thing came to a head under the
iran-contra scandal and once again the
establishment was faced in in the winter
of 87 they were saying you know we've
had it the people the people have had it
and we're going to have to give them the
Democrats for a while and they came up
eventually with with what was to them a
brilliant the perfect candidate was
Dukakis who had a reputation of being
clean after the corruption of the Reagan
years who had a reputation of being
somewhat of a populist as Jimmy Carter
did who could be sold as a cleansing
sort of as here you know we sympathize
here you can have your president for a
while the truth is that that Jimmy
Carter had foisted upon him the big
Rosinski you know it was an utter
fastest in his policies to control the
national security decisions so Carter's
human rights stuff couldn't go too far
and he wound up setting in motion the
arms build-up that eventually evolved
into the Reagan arms build-up which is
the biggest peacetime buildup in the
history of the biggest buildup in the
arms buildup in the history of the world
moved into the bush camp and during this
county indeed and at and of course
that's part of the October the election
held hostage the the playboy article
brings it out very clearly is that
having put he doesn't get into their
having put a Carter in office to plaque
hate the people after Nixon after
Vietnam after the civil rights struggle
that then gets into that but they're
taking it up at the time of at the end
of the Carter era era where two things
had happened one is the Federal Reserve
Board cooked the economy and so we had
runaway inflation which would scare
people you could feel it you could taste
it and the newspapers talked about it
every day and blamed it on Carter and
when when he doesn't control the stuff
the Federal Reserve Board does and then
the other thing was the national
security establishment went after him
with a passion the CIA operatives
cooperating with Bush Reagan during the
presidential campaign of 1980 the
Pentagon cooperating MacFarlane their
Marine officer working on the State
Department advising but having committed
himself to the bush side all of these
these tendrils go back to the security
establishment saying okay we've given
them Carter for four years now let's get
back to work and they got they got
Reagan in there to summarize they got
Reagan in there and he eventually
self-destructed or the system
self-destructed under his watch they
thought they were going to have to give
us Dukakis to placate the people and
then they found that the people simply
don't care enough the people simply
aren't vigilant enough of their own
interest to care enough about this
monumental corruption from George Bush
and and the people around him and they
were able to continue with the eighteen
in office with George Bush to extend and
continue the policies of Ronald Reagan
to exploit the nation and to keep in
lockstep with the drug runners not to
mention the military machinery